Welcome to your second
epidemiology lecture.
The session
objectives are similar
to your first
epidemiology section,
but the measures
we'll be talking
about are a little
more complex.
We will go through
every type of study
design that is important
in epidemiological
studies and then follow
with which measures
are calculated in
each circumstance.
The take-home here
is going to be that
there are many study
designs and each one
has benefits and
limitations. Each of them
have different measures,
and you have to
figure out which
ones to use in which
situation so that you
can quantify disease.
With that, we're
going to look
at another
fictitious case.
So let's say that
when you were a child,
your mother constantly
told you that
you shouldn't go out
in the winter without
a hat as you'll catch
a cold. Now as a
medical professional,
you're ready to
prove her wrong. So
you decide to dedicate
your life to
investigating this issue.
So we're going to
start with a cross
-sectional study. A
cross-sectional study
is a one-time sweep
through a time
point to assess the
prevalence of variables,
diseases, and risk
factors. You can
collect the data
first and then divide
people into groups
for comparisons.
You can't really
talk about risk or
incidence because
it was a one-time
measurement with
no element of time.
So how would you do
this? Well, you wouldn't
have any regard for
people's cold status or
use of hats. So you
could send out a survey
to a mass general
population asking about
both, and then see if
you find associations
between the two. But
the problem is, if
everybody writes down
that they are getting a
cold, or if everybody
says that they wear a
hat, you can't do an
analysis because you don't
have any comparison
groups. So most people
would go with a
different approach where
you're guaranteed to
have two or more groups.
So then let's look at
a case control study.
In a case control study
with two groups, one
group has the disease
of interest, and these
are the cases. The
comparable group is
free from disease, and
these are the controls.
The case control study
identifies possible
causes of disease by
finding out how the two
groups differ with
respect to an exposure.
So how would you design
this? So first you
have to find your
inclusion criteria.
That is, how do you
define people who get
colds? Is it just
somebody who says, I get
colds? Or are you
going to go into their
medical record and
it's certain ICD codes?
Are you going to recruit
from a clinic? Are
you going to put
something out on Facebook
or Instagram or Twitter?
So you have to figure
out how you actually
define a case. Then
you need healthy
controls. And that's not
usually as easy as it
sounds, because where
are you going to find
these people? There
are a lot of different
sources. You can use
general population
controls or general medical
clinics. If you
want to do a matched
analysis, you'd find
somebody that is in some way
linked to the cases.
So it could be spouses
or friends. You
would then survey the
groups and ask in detail
about their use of
hats. And the goal is
to compare hat wearing
in the cases to hat
wearing in the controls.
Now, selecting the
controls, again, general
population controls
were far easier at a
time where you could
actually do things
like random digit
dialing or get residence
lists or driver's
license records. Those
things, because of
privacy rules and the lack
of anybody having a
landline, have gotten
much, much harder to
do. In addition to
that, if you did
personally get a phone call
and somebody asked
you to take a survey,
my guess is the first
thing you'd do is
hang up. So this isn't
necessarily something
that's easy. Now,
there are methods where
you can recruit
general controls using
sources like Amazon,
but these things may or
may not be the best
approach. And what a
lot of people do is try
to figure out whether
this is really going
to get you the right
result. The advantage
being you can make
sure that you recruit
from the same population
as your cases, but
the disadvantage
being it's time-consuming
and expensive and
you probably won't
get great cooperation.
A lot of people will go
to clinic or hospital
controls. The reason
they do this is that
this is a group of
people you might have
access to. So you could
call up your friend
in a different clinic
who's a primary care
doctor and see if they
want to participate in
the study. It's easy
to identify these
patients and accessible,
and the same general
factors led them to the
hospital. And if you're
using your cases from
a hospital, these
may be all people who
have similar health
behavior in terms of
caring for their health.
Also, because they
are all going to
the clinic, their
amount of recall with
what they were doing
or not doing might
be a little more
comparable, and
they're usually more
willing to participate
than a general
population control.
There are disadvantages.
So hospitals usually
see people who are sick.
Most people don't go
hang out at the hospital
or a clinic because
they feel great. Now,
you may be able to get
somebody who's going
in just for their
general physical, but
this is something you
really need to pay
attention to. So just
like you had inclusion
criteria for your cases,
you would have inclusion
and exclusion criteria
for your controls.
Also, depending on
which hospital you
use, it may not
actually have the same
population as your
patients. So these
are all things to
pay attention to.
What illnesses would
actually make good
hospital controls? Well,
really, it would be
if they have an illness
and it has absolutely
no relation to the
risk factor that
you're studying. So
for example, should
respiratory diseases be
used as a control in a
study of smoking and
myocardial infarction.
That is, do they
represent the distribution
of smoking in the
general population
that gave rise to
the cases of MI?
So probably not.
You could, again,
consider special control
groups like friends,
spouses, siblings,
even deceased
individuals. However, all
those things have
different mathematical
methods, so it could
complicate things.
People like to match
in epidemiology,
and there are different
ways to do it.
You can do it
individually where it's
each person matched
to somebody, or you
could do it by
frequency where 20% are
a certain age group,
the next 20% are
in a different age
group. But again,
analysis has to take
that into account.
Matching can be
great. It can be time
efficient. It can be
cost effective. It can
be good for your
statistics. But the more
things you match on,
the harder it is to
actually find an actual
control. And then
once you've matched
people on things,
you've already interfered
with that variable
and you can't actually
study it anymore.
So analysis of results
in a case control
study includes the
odds ratio, and
this is looking at
an unmatched study.
And it could be
described either as
odds of exposure in
the diseased divided
by odds of exposure
in the healthy.
Or because in this
case, mathematically,
it just happens to
work, you could also say
odds of disease and
exposed versus odds
of disease and unexposed.
So you can kind
of see how this is
divided out in a table.
You have people
classified as yes or no by
disease status, and then
yes or no is exposure
status. And you
can see that you've
calculated the odds of
disease in the exposed
and the odds of disease
in the unexposed,
and you just divide
to get the odds ratio.
So you can see in
this example where
a fictitious case
has actually been
done, and this is
looking at Parkinson's
disease and coffee
consumption.
And you have your cases
who have Parkinson's
disease and your
controls who are
healthy. And then they're
classified as yes or
no in terms of coffee
drinking. And when
you calculate the
numbers, you get 1.3.
And how you interpret
it is to say a PD
patient is 1.3 times
as likely as a healthy
individual to have
been a coffee drinker.
Now, we're not going
to talk a lot about the
statistics because
you have separate
statistics lectures,
but it's hard to mention
epidemiological measures
without also mentioning
the need to think
about statistical
significance. So when
you calculate an odds
ratio the way I did on
the previous page, that
doesn't tell you
whether that result is
statistically significant.
So in real life,
you still need a p
-value. And in general, p
-values below 0.05 are
considered significant
in science, although
that can vary based on
the situation. And
when you have a ratio,
you usually also report
something called a
95% confidence
interval. And because in
ratios, if you divide
two equal numbers, you
get one. One is
considered the null value.
Null doesn't mean zero.
Null means there's no
effect. So if in your
division the number
that you're getting for
one group is identical
to the other group,
you would divide the
two and get one and
one would be the null
value, meaning there's
no association. And
in this case, it would
actually be reflected
in the confidence
interval. The confidence
interval would have one
in it and that tells
you that it's not
significant. Now, case
control studies are
very good for rare
diseases and diseases
that have a long induction
or latent period. The
reason for that is
that if something is
rare, you're better off
collecting it. Otherwise,
it's never going
to happen. If you
collect people without
the disease, but it's
very rare, now you're
having to wait for
the disease to happen.
That's not very
efficient. It's much more
efficient to do it this
way, which is to go find
the people with the
disease, collect them,
and then base the
study around them. So
that is the basis of a
case control study that
you are first picking
people by their
disease status. It's good
because you can evaluate
a lot of risk
factors for the same
disease. So if you
don't know a lot about a
disease, which is often
the case with rare
disease, now you have
the opportunity to ask
them about a lot of
exposures, not just one.
There are, however,
weaknesses. If it's a
rare exposure, let's
say you're trying to
study a very unusual
dietary supplement, the
chances are almost
everybody is going to
say, no, I've never
heard of that. And so
now you're not really
studying it. So this
isn't the best situation.
If the whole goal
of your study is to
find out about a rare
exposure, it's also
vulnerable to bias
because it's retrospective.
A case control
study is always
retrospective because again,
you've selected
people by disease, the
disease has happened.
so you can only ask them
about what happened in
the past. It's fairly
common to have poor
information about
exposures when they're
retrospective and
because it's retrospective
it's really hard
to infer a temporal
relationship between
exposure and disease.
You weren't there to see
it happen so you don't
necessarily know.
So then given that
you decide you don't
want to do a case
control study it's
not optimal so
let's say you decide
I'm going to do a
cohort study instead.
And this is the
right way to figure
out whether or
not I really had
to wear a hat or
whether my mom was
just nagging me.
This is your way.
So in a cohort study,
you have two groups
that don't have disease
at the beginning. So
the hallmark of this
study versus a case
control study is that
absolutely nobody had
disease at the beginning
of your study. You
are then going to
select people by their
exposure. So you're
going to pick out the
people who have the
exposure, you're going to
pick out people who
don't have the exposure,
and then you're going
to wait and you're
going to follow them
forward and see who
gets the disease. And
is the disease equal
in both groups or is it
the same? Now, I want
to call attention
to the fact that a
retrospective study is
also possible within the
definition of a cohort
study. And the reason
for that is that you
have access to things
like medical records.
So a retrospective
cohort study goes into
the medical record,
and then you have
to imagine your time
traveling, let's say,
back 20 years, and you're
going to start reading
the medical record
from 20 years ago. And
so now you actually
have the temporal
relationship because let's
say you're reading
about patient Jane Doe
and you've started
reading about her 20
years ago in her medical
record and at the
time she didn't have
the disease and then you
follow through, you're
reading, reading,
reading, and eventually
she gets the disease.
So it's still a cohort
study because the
beginning of your study
definition period,
everybody is going
to be disease-free,
but in actuality
it's retrospective
because everything
has actually happened.
So how would you
design a cohort study?
Let's just say you're
going to design a regular
prospective cohort
study. Well, here,
again, everybody has
to be healthy, but
first you'd recruit the
people who wear hats.
That's your exposure.
So you're going to,
again, decide on your
inclusion criteria.
Is it all hats? Is
it wool hats? Can a
beret be okay? This
is, I mean, obviously a
silly example, but
you do have to be very
nitpicky in terms
of really designing
medical research. And
then you would have to
find the control group
with no exposure or
people who say, I
would never wear a hat.
Then you would follow
them through time to
calculate an incidence
rate of colds in
the hat wearers versus
the non-hat wearers.
It is a very good study
designed for
rare exposures.
Again, when something's
rare, you're
best off collecting
people who have that.
In a retrospective
cohort study, it's
actually very efficient
for diseases that take
a long time. So if it
has a long induction
or latent period,
I mean, you're just
reading. It's a lot
different than having to
sit around waiting for
the disease to happen.
It's all happened,
and you can just read
about it. And you
can, again, evaluate
multiple effects of an
exposure. So it's kind
of reverse of a case
control study. So if
you say, my goal is
to study the exposure
of hats on colds,
that's fine, but there's
nothing to stop you
from asking about
migraines, heart attacks,
whatever you want
to ask about, because
all those things
theoretically are going
to happen after the
exposure, and so you
can ask about anything.
You do have a temporal
relationship if
it's a prospective
study, and you can get
pretty good information
on the exposures,
so it's a little less
vulnerable to bias.
There are weaknesses.
It's not great for a
rare outcome. So if a
disease is just rare,
honestly, you could
collect a whole bunch
of people and maybe
one person gets the
disease or maybe nobody
gets the disease.
So then again, in this
case, it just wouldn't
make sense to go with
this study design.
If it's retrospective,
you might have
poor information on
exposure and other
variables because
again, remember, we're
talking about things
like medical records. And
that information
wasn't gathered to do
medical research. It was
gathered for clinical
reasons. So doctors
and nurses have
jotted down exactly
what they need to jot
down to stay compliant,
but they're busy,
they're in a hurry,
and they had no idea 20
years later somebody
is going to look at
this for research. So
honestly, the variables
may not be recorded
in the best way.
But the flip side
is when things are
prospective, it's
expensive, it's time
-consuming, and again,
it's not great for
diseases that are
rare or that take a
very, very long time
to happen. So these
are the things to keep
in mind when you're
comparing with a
case control study.
Now, the basic
analysis of a cohort
study doesn't look
that different than
the analysis of a
case control study.
The table looks
almost identical.
And so once again, you
have disease status
and you have exposure
status. But what
makes this table
different than the case
control study table
really has to do with the
study design. The table
itself looks almost
identical. But if you
look, you no longer
have to calculate an
odds. You can calculate
an incidence rate.
And an incidence
rate is considered far
superior to an odds.
So when you're allowed
to do one, you do
that. The reason you
can do the incidence
rate is that everybody
was disease-free at
the beginning of the
study. So anything you
had in your study
period is considered
new disease. And so
all a relative risk is,
is an incidence rate
in one group divided
by the incidence rate
in the other group.
Now, in this kind of
study, you can also
get some additional
measures. You can get
something called an
attributable risk,
which is based on
subtraction, But what
you most often see
is the relative risk.
And again, it would
look like this. And
interpreting it is really
identical to a case
control study. We're
not going to spend a
lot of time on it
because this isn't a
statistics lecture. But
again, when you have a
relative risk of one,
that was because you
divided two identical
numbers. Both groups
had the same incidence
rate, and that's the
same as saying no
risk. Above one is an
elevated risk. Below
one is a reduced risk.
Okay, so let's just
say all of these study
designs to you just
seem substandard and you
found out the gold
standard in epidemiology
studies is a randomized
controlled trial.
Now, this is absolutely
the case. So most
of the time when a
drug goes to market or
when a procedure is
recommended, it's gone
through a randomized
controlled trial, and
that's what's required
in order to actually
go forward on a new
medical treatment. So
let's say in this case,
you decide to spend
all of your time,
money, and effort, and
you create a controlled
winter chamber,
and you recruit 400
people to live under a
controlled setting
where you're going to
randomize people into
a hat or no hat group.
Now this may seems
silly, but I don't know
how many of you have
seen they actually have
these weird frozen
chambers for people now
where people can go
stand in the cold on
purpose. So this is
actually a doable study.
The huge difference
here is that you
have randomized
people. This isn't
what they chose
to do in nature.
It's where you put
them. And the benefit
in it is that if
you randomized,
then there's less
bias. People aren't
self-selecting
things. And the
analysis is actually
same as the cohort
study. You can get
a relative risk.
So a randomized
control trial allows a
couple of things that
other study designs
don't allow. The
first is the use of a
placebo, which can be
used to make groups
as comparable as
possible. And the
second is blinding.
So you can make it so
that it's single
blind, where subjects
don't know whether
they're getting treatment
or placebo or
double blind where
nobody knows who's
getting the treatment.
And the purpose of
this, of course,
attributable risk.
Okay. We're going to
shift to talking
about some more nitty
gritties of studies.
So we've talked about
study designs as
though disease and
exposures are very,
very clean cut, but in
actuality, they're
not clean cut at all
because human beings,
unlike lab rats, are
not genetically
identical. They don't
have identical
environments. They each
have a bunch of factors
that also affect
disease, and this is
what confounding is.
Confounding is talking
about an alternate
explanation for the
observed association
between an exposure
and a disease.
So what if you see that
those who wear hats
get fewer colds, but
then you dig a little
deeper and you find
out the same people
who wear hats also wear
gloves and scarves.
So what if it was
really the scarf that
protects against colds?
Maybe the hat had
nothing to do with it.
So in this particular
study, the scarf
became a confounder
because you weren't
trying to study the
scarf, but that's what
you ended up getting.
So this is why you
collect data on
variables other
than the ones you're
studying and the common
ones that everybody
asks about are age,
gender, and race. You
can address confounding
by stratification or
with more complicated
regression analysis.
Regression is beyond
the scope of this
class, but we will
talk about stratifying.
So here's an example
where you are
looking at a situation
where you want to
know about heart
attacks and smoking.
So let's just say
your composite
OR. OR stands
for odds ratio.
Composite means that
you didn't account
for anything. You did
the math exactly how
I showed you. You
only looked at heart
attacks and it was a
yes or a no. And then
you looked at smoking
and it was a yes or
a no. And you got an
odds ratio of 2.15.
But then you decide,
I need to make sure
that there's no
confounding. So you decide
you're going to
stratify. You look at the
males and you look at
the females separately.
And now you calculate
the odds ratio and
you see that it's
different than what
you got as the
composite. What happened
here is that there was
confounding by gender.
And then when you
teased it out, when
you put people in
their own categories,
you see that there
is a new odds ratio.
Now, you can tell
that it's confounding
because the new odds
ratio is pretty much
the same in males and
females. So now you
can say one is the
true odds ratio. But
you want to keep
this in mind when we
compare it to effect
modification, which we're
going to talk about,
because here again,
with confounding,
you're seeing that
both numbers are one.
Once you stratified,
you got a new odds
ratio, but it was
identical in both of
your stratified groups.
Effect modification is
a different phenomenon.
It's talking about
when an exposure
behaves differently in
different groups. So for
example, if you find
smoking increases the
risk for heart attacks
much more in males
than females. Now, these
are fictional. It's
not based on fact.
But let's just say it
has to do with hormones.
And for whatever
reason, women have
additional factors that
make them less likely
to be affected. Now,
you would have effect
modification. Now, the
process of finding
that is similar. So in
this, again, fictional
example, the composite
odds ratio was 6.83.
But then I stratified.
And now you see for
females, the odds
ratio was 3.86, but in
males, the odds ratio
was nine. So this is
not confounding because
what this is showing
you is that the odds
ratio is simply different
if you're a male.
How much the smoking
was affecting the heart
attacks, it was much
more so in males than
females. So this is
effect modification.
So then the answer to
how you would address,
either interaction or
confounding an analysis,
is stratification.
They're very different
things, but they have
the same solution.
Okay, the final thing
we're going to talk
about is bias. So bias
is a systematic error
that results in an
incorrect estimate of
your measure of
association. It can go in
any direction. It can
say that there's no
association when there
really is one. It can
find an association
and it's not supposed
to be there. And we're
not talking about
something that is done
on purpose. It's just
something that's
introduced by either the
study investigator
or the participants.
Now, the word bias
does not mean that the
investigator is prejudiced.
It's, again, not
anything people do on
purpose, but it has
to do with bad study
design. And it can occur
in all study types,
you know, experimental
cohort case control.
And it happens when
you're designing and
conducting the study.
The problem with
it is that you can
acknowledge it, but you
can't fix it. There's no
statistics that fixes
bias once you're
past the stage of having
collected the data.
We're going to talk
about just a few types
of bias. One is
selection bias. So this
results from procedures
used to select subjects
into a study that
lead to a particular
result because of the
way you selected them.
So perhaps you're
looking at a study of
physical activity and
Parkinson's disease, but
you selected everybody
from an exercise
clinic. So there's a
selection bias here because
everybody you actually
picked are exercisers.
So this just, again,
it's not something
somebody did on
purpose. Maybe they did
it because that's who
was available to them,
but it's not representative
of Parkinson's
patients who aren't
in an exercise clinic.
The other major one
is recall bias. So
people don't
necessarily always have
accurate memories, and
it can, again, go in
any direction. It
could be that people
who have a disease
remember or report
exposures differently
because they're over
searching their
memories. They're
trying really hard to
find an explanation.
But it could also be
that somebody with a
disease feels guilty.
And so they're trying
not to actually
remember something that
they did. So it
really just comes down
to people's recall is
not necessarily always
the most accurate,
but this is why you
try to do things to
kind of mitigate that.
So you use controls
who are themselves
sick, you standardize
questionnaires, mask
subjects, you try to
do what you can, but
any study has some
level of bias in it.
There are many other
kinds of biases. We
can't cover them in a
lecture, but the concept
is always the same.
The study is designed
in a way that is getting
you flawed results.
Okay, so now we've
gone through several
study designs as
well as exactly what
you do with those
study designs, how you
assess them, the
problems that can occur
in them. And the take
-home is that there
are a lot of study
designs. Each one
has different benefits
and limitations.
Bias confounding
and effect
modification can occur
in any study design,
and each of
them should be
addressed in every
given study design.
Okay, so that concludes
this epidemiology
session, and please
just make sure that you
understand all of the
listed objectives.